Hello Freak bitches.
But what they're essentially doing is
just piecing together what they think is
like an argument based on
these predetermined patterns
that they've picked up.
Exactly.
Like,
you know,
as you as a white male wouldn't understand
a woman of color what fucking color
you will like what you're white.
I mean you're,
you're Asian,
but I mean when you're talking
about the color of your skin,
you can't say color.
You just can't,
you might want to say ethnicity.
You might want to say,
you know,
uh,
whatever,
background.
Mm.
Well,
I mean,
look,
let me clarify.
There is,
I completely concede that there is a
lived experience of being a certain,
being a minority ethnicity,
especially in America or in Australia,
um,
new countries that is different
from being a white man.
I absolutely concede that.
The thing is why can't we talk about
the actual details of the experience
without assuming that
there's a homogeneity between
that experience as well.
Like not every Asian experience
in America is the same.
They have certain commonalities in that
they're subject to racism in a way that
you and I aren't,
but they are so wildly different.
Let's talk about the details
of the experience and what's
acceptable and how we,
how we want to converse with one another.
Let's not assume that because a person
has a particular set bunch of labels
attached to them,
gay,
straight,
Asian,
white man,
woman,
whatever,
that that immediately disqualifies them
from having a conversation about these
things.
It's weird when you look at people
from that error and you consider
that was him.
I get that.
We're fucking groovy mustache.
Wouldn't you love to go back in
time and hang out with John L.
Sullivan?
We use the fucking heavyweight
champion of the world.
Yeah.
Can you imagine some of
the old school puts you,
that guy got old school place.
You imagine what it must've been like.
Just a funny saying.
In Sullivan's era,
no formal boxing titles existed.
He became a champion after defeating
Patty Ryan and Mississippi City near Gulf
Port Mississippi on February 7th,
1882 modern authorities have retroactively
labeled Ryan the heavyweight champion
of America.
But any claim to Ryan being a world
champion would have been dubious.
He had never contended
internationally as Sullivan had.
I could lick Patty Ryan,
not crazy.
Sullivan was first considered the world
heavyweight champion after either 1888
when he fought Charlie Mitchell in France
or the following year when he knocked
out Jake kill rain in a ready
for this round 75 I told you,
wow.
Have a scheduled 80 round.
They a schedule the schedule.
I didn't even know the head
of the end told off fuck set.
Round 75 that hurts my head.
Just how long was he drowned though?
Is he trying to like two seconds?
I think it was three minutes.
I think it was just like it is today.
Fucking,
Hey,
what does an in time,
what does that and what the
fuck is 75 times fat and a half,
two hours,
225 minutes.
So it's a,
Oh my God,
that's sane.
I think they're doing a podcast.
That's insane.
Can you imagine bare knuckle
boxing a guy for three hours?
How much do you believe in,
whether it is DNA or a soul or something
like something that's purely uniquely
about that person when they are born
and that's part of our day are or match
matches called a cherry.
You know the famous nurture
versus culture debate.
What,
what's your take on what's
more important in this?
I don't know.
Well they have done studies where they've
taken twins that were separated at
birth,
there were adopted and they
get them together after not
seeing each other entire
life and they find out they
like the same kind of music.
Really?
Yeah.
They have very similar likes and dislikes.
Their personalities are very similar.
There's a strong argument
for nature over nurture.
Right.
But there's no denying that
nurture plays a huge role as well.
I should take,
it's either or.
I think we live in a soup of possibilities
and I think that you can get super
lucky with the amount of exposure that
you have to positive and even to negative
things.
Like there's an expression,
hard times make good people,
you know,
and I do believe that in a certain
sense that there's some experiences that
children and adults even have that
they get through and it makes them more
empathetic.
It makes them kinder and make some
more understanding and it makes them
stronger,
like more,
more character.
Even that the way,
it's funny because you're right,
I mean there's part of that
argument that's south at
through and you do see that
happen a lot and then you see somebody
who was through the exact same thing and
it makes them 10 times more of an asshole.
He's like,
I go heart song on her and everybody
else into pyrolysis and of them and he's
like that.
That's where you think like what is the
make these one person make a right turn
and go in and their action where they
become kinder and nicer because they felt
what it is to get hurt and what is the
other one may make the complete opposite
turn and go in a direction of Aiga hearts.
I don't care for anybody else's feeding.
Everybody has to pay for the
Fed that I go heart ones.
Yeah.
It's weird,
right?
It's like there's that moment where you
can really make a 90 degree turn one way
or another.
What is the make people
make the choices they make.
And I think hormones have a stigma in
this country because of Barry bonds and
fucking Sammy Sosa and all this
crazy shit where everybody's like,
oh,
this is fucking cheaters in baseball.
They ruined everything and sports
and everyone is so concerned with um,
what we hear about with
cheating and steroids and
athletic performance that then
you're missing out on a core essential
aspect of being a human being,
being a man,
especially um,
the lack of testosterone
directly related to depression,
directly related to these,
these people that start hitting age
regardless of traumatic brain injury,
they start getting older and
they feel like fucking shit.
They feel like shit.
And I've talked to a lot of them that
get on testosterone and all of a sudden
their glow again,
they have energy.
They want to start doing
things there are active.
And someone I've talked to guys who are
on testosterone that don't like to talk
about it because they're worried that
someone's going to look at them first of
all as being inferior
because they need to add,
you know,
artificial testosterone to
their system and that they're,
they might be a roid head now.
They might be a cheater and some like,
what are you fucking planet?
You're 55 years old,
you playing major league baseball
behind my back with the life,
your life tutor,
you're doing too good with these new home.
Meanwhile you'll take aspirin
if you have a fucking headache,
you take Ibuprofen,
you'll take medication if you're sick.
Like why won't you take testosterone?
Why won't you get your
hormone levels change?
I have a very good friend that won't
do it because he's afraid of all these
other things.
I'm like,
Bro,
you look like shit
tired all the time.
Like what do you worry about?
And the difference to me is like us
being there and these guys who like I sat
down with a guy two weeks ago,
wrote a script about a,
met him for the first time.
Lovely guy,
like the sweetest,
sweetest,
nicest guy,
loves to fish and all this and I'm like,
so how is it like we
really get down to basics.
He's like,
it's good man,
it's good,
but some days I just have to find a
reason to go on live in and you're just
like,
you understand at that point how
different it is for these guys,
like how much more drastic it is,
how much more important it is to
to reach out to these guys and,
and somebody's got to do it.
What about panda bears?
Are they vicious?
Vicious rapist.
Okay.
Horrible racists.
Pan Is the worst.
Koala bears.
Very lot of sexually transmitted disease.
Chlamydia like for real,
that's all.
Bears transmit sexually transmitted
diseases to each other or they die people.
I think two is once you get the clap,
I never cheat on you with people.
It was so cute and then he
just starts fucking man.
It's weird.
Koala bears there.
It's killing them though.
Like as an eight,
it's threatening to take 'em out.
Midea the STD threatening and Australian
icon gone take them down a planned
parenthood.
What late that gets kind of,
here's the thing,
man,
we're so funny with what
we want to keep around.
You know we have this idea that we
are in charge somehow or another,
making sure that animals don't go extinct
and the like Koala bear needs to stay
around.
Right?
Like does it really,
I mean I don't think we
should go kill them all.
Okay.
I don't think that,
but if they all died
because of fucking herpes.
Yeah.
I think maybe we should concentrate on
poor people before we concentrate on
herpes.
Written Koala bears.
Absolutely.
Dude,
you're writing crazy sense of,
but when it comes to that shit,
you can accidentally get
an STD from a coauthor.
Okay.
That's what you should have.
You should have called bears
in your house that way.
You always have a built in me.
He should get a fucking Koala.
It's not what you think Connie babies.
Look,
I'm going to show you
the article on Google.
It's a pdf file.
Your House and Edu address.
Your House has just tanning beds and cool.
Just so you have an hour.
I'll shit that can give you STDs.
Seats.
Has anybody ever really gotten to a
Tammy bed venereal diseases that real?
I have no idea.
I didn't.
I know.
This is the first I'm hearing of this.
Yeah.
You can get,
supposedly you can get
herpes from a tanning bed.
Get herpes from a toilet seat.
No,
you can you,
yeah.